there's a few topics we talked about
that kind of interconnect
because because i wonder the better i
get at certain things
we humans
the deeper we understand something
what are you starting to then miss about
the rest of the world
we talked about uh
david and his uh degenerative
mind
and you know when you look in the mirror
and wonder
how different am i am i cognitively from
the man i i was a month ago from the man
i was a year ago like what
you know
if i can um
having thought about language if i'm
chomsky for for 10 20 years
what am i no longer able to see what is
in my blind spot and how big is that
and then to somehow be able to leap back
out of your deep like
structure that you form for yourself
about thinking about the world leap back
and look at the big picture again
or jump out of the your current way of
thinking
um and be able to introspect like what
are the limitations of your mind
are how is your mind less powerful than
you used to be or more powerful or
different powerful in different ways so
that that seems to be a difficult thing
to do because we're living we're looking
at the world through the lens of our
mind right to step outside and
introspect it's difficult but it seems
necessary if you want to make progress
you know one of the
threads of psychological research that's
always been very um
i don't know important to me to be aware
of is is is
the idea that
um our explanations of our own behavior
aren't necessarily
actually
part of the causal process that caused
that behavior to occur
or even
valid observations of the set of
constraints that led to the outcome but
they are post-hoc rationalizations that
we can give based on
information at our disposal about what
might have contributed to
the result that we came to uh when asked
and um so this this is an idea that was
introduced in a
very important paper
by nisbet and wilson about
you know the limits on our ability to to
be aware of
the factors
that cause us to make the choices that
we make
um and um
you know
i think it's
it's uh
it's something that we really ought to
be much more
um
cognizant of in general as human beings
is that
our own insight into exactly why we hold
the beliefs that we do and we hold the
attitudes and make the choices and
and and feel the feelings that we do is
not something that we
um
we totally control or
totally observe and
um
it's subject to
you know
uh our
culturally transmitted understanding of
what it is that is the mode that we give
to explain
uh these things uh when asked to do so
as much as it is about anything else and
so
even our ability to introspect and think
we have
access to our own thoughts as a product
of of culture and belief you know
practice
you